well we're really in the middle of a
master class in propaganda from the
American right wing The Narrative
continues to shift about this Chinese
surveillance balloon which was popped
shot out of the sky on the orders of
President Joe Biden who will no doubt
talk about the balloon at tonight's
State of the Union Address which by the
way I will be covering live and I hope
that you will join me for initially the
narrative was Joe Biden is weak and he
won't pop the balloon The Narrative then
became well Biden popped it but any
president would have popped the balloon
so it's not really worthy of much praise
now it is starting to become why did
Biden pop the balloon there were other
better options from some esteemed
military strategists such as
Newt Gingrich
yeah Newt Gingrich weighing in on Fox
News saying we could have scooped it why
wasn't it scooped it was the wrong thing
to pop it and only then after it's all
done bring it down and then bring it
down in such a way that now they're
having to go out and try to find it in
the ocean I mean we had plenty of
capacity to to scoop that balloon out of
the air we used to do it all the time
with Satellite photographs back before
you had electronic transmission right
we'd have planes that would go up and
actually capture the cab the capsule
that had the the uh the satellite the
Spy material yeah now of course the
sizes of the these things dramatically
different and you know I don't know what
sort of super duper pooper scooper Newt
Gingrich has in mind here but I wasn't
able to find anything about scoopers for
scooping stuff up as big as three buses
at 66 000 feet I believe it was or
whatever the case may be now does does
it mean that that doesn't exist well I
don't know Newt Gingrich is someone who
has been out of any position of power
for a very long time and there is no
question that Joe Biden was given all of
the options Newt Gingrich certainly
doesn't even know what they are now one
other thing I don't know why no one is
proposing what really should have been
done send astronaut George Anthony
Katara devolder Santos up to grab the
thing himself that really would have
been the the solution obviously
um listen Newt Gingrich specifically is
sort of like a joke he's kind of like
the punch line to whatever joke makes
sense at this point in time he's the guy
who said that under his if you were to
call it leadership by 2021 we would have
had a permanent Colony on the moon so
not really a serious guy but this is
really all about propaganda and it's all
about narrative and it's about this idea
that you can't allow any Democrat
president if you're a republican to get
anything right anything anything right
at even the smallest level Joe Biden can
do no right and as I've told you before
I am on the left I believe that
Progressive policies are better for the
country I believe Modern Republicanism
is an absolute disaster but when Trump
got something right I would tell you
whether it was a couple of the tweaks to
the tax code in 2017 that did make sense
or elements of the first step act or the
reality that Trump really didn't deserve
blame for Rising inflation and gas
prices at the end of it let's call
things what they are
and this is relatively uncontroversial
Joe Biden doing what at the end of the
day military advisors put to to him
which are also the same limitations that
Donald Trump would have had so the new
story is why shoot it down we could have
pooper scooped it and then brought it
down or whatever the case may be
if you want to hear an elected official
really relating to the plight of the
average man or woman in the United
States I can think of no better example
than radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene
whining that she only makes a hundred
and seventy four thousand dollars as a
member of Congress and now she has to
work most of the year if you can imagine
imagine that most of the year she has to
work and she's only getting paid 174
thousand dollars while flying back and
forth between DC and her District on
taxpayer funded airline travel
I know this is sort of like when Trump
talks about his plane and it's super
relatable when he shows up in the middle
of nowhere Oklahoma on his private plane
and whines about how he had to totally
refurbish it in front of a crowd that
statistically wouldn't be able to meet a
400 unexpected expense without incurring
debt of some kind
almost as unrelatable as Marjorie Taylor
green she appeared recently on the by
the way that
she appeared on Glenn greenwald's Rumble
show which is sort of like a a lead-in
to a completely uh to another story
altogether which I don't have time for
today on Glenn greenwald's Rumble show
here is Marjorie Taylor green bemoaning
she's miserable now that she's a member
of Congress the salary is low and it's
so much work for her the nature of this
job it keeps members of Congress and
senators in Washington so much of the
time uh too much of the time to be
honest with you that that we don't get
to go home and spend more time with our
families our friends
um you know all in our district or maybe
just be regular people
how relatable huh because this job is so
Factory workers All Over Georgia are
sympathizing with us demanding that's
turned into practically your around and
and for those they expect me to work
almost the entire year that's in the
House of Representatives we have to run
for Congress every two years so you're
practically campaigning nearly the
entire time that's a fair criticism that
you're here serving as a representative
so that's that's just a couple of
examples that I can give you that I
believe is a recipe for disaster and
that's how people just fall into
um this social club I I would call it a
social club here in Washington DC now
for me I I have no interest in that I
really don't and I'll tell you why yeah
becoming a member of Congress has made
my life miserable made a lot more money
my life is also miserable because she's
in Congress so it's not it's not that
she didn't only do this to herself she
did it to many of us before I got here
I've lost money since I've gotten here I
have people come up to me and say crazy
things to me out of the blue in public
places that they believe because they
read it on the Internet or saw it on
some some new show right that's never
happened to her about me uh so it's not
it's not a life that I think is is like
um something that I enjoy uh because you
can resign Marjorie you didn't have to
run for re-election by the way don't
enjoy it but I'm committed to this job
because I believe in it yeah
um not a single redeeming quality about
this woman now let's actually sort of
like be thorough here how does Marjorie
Taylor Green's 174 000 salary compare
you know you can you can look this stuff
up we're gonna first start with income
percentile calculator this is for the
United States and if we type in her
salary 174 thousand dollars uh for I
guess what we will call full-time work
she is in the 92nd percentile 92nd
percentile meaning
um that she makes more than 92 percent
of Americans working full-time but eight
percent of Americans make more than she
does and then if we look at for her age
right Marjorie Taylor green is 48 years
old so we can calculate this as well 174
000 a year uh whoops that's 1.7 million
and she is also in the 92nd percentile
there so you know it is not untrue that
people can make a lot more money in the
private sector that that's absolutely
true can Marjorie make more money in the
private sector because it's not exactly
clear to me what skills or competency
she has many people make more than a
hundred and seventy four thousand
dollars but it's just not clear to me
that Marjorie Taylor green would be one
of those people I don't understand
how poor white people in Georgia
love a woman who bemoans that she has to
work almost the entire year for only a
hundred and seventy four thousand
dollars a year that is really the
greatest scam
perpetrated by the Republican party on
the American people on their electorate
and this goes back to the Tea Party of
2010. this goes back to economic policy
that would do nothing for the very
people who say hey you know what let's
vote for lower taxes for the rich Let's
vote for people who will complain about
a hundred and seventy four thousand
dollar salary the only person may be
more repugnant than Marjorie Taylor
green would be her colleague who I guess
now she hates Lauren bobert and I want
to talk about Lauren bobert a little bit
here before we go to our first break
Lauren bobert has now repeatedly prayed
for the death of President Joe Biden
tonight is the State of the Union
Address Joe Biden will address the
nation I will be streaming live on
YouTube twitch and Facebook starting a
little after 8 PM Eastern and I hope
that you'll join me so we can see what
Joe Biden has to say and if in whether
he unveils new policy tonight
it actually would make sense
for Secret Service to take extra care
when screening certain people tonight
and one of those people is Lauren bober
I'm going to play a clip for you of
Lauren bobert at you know some church
she does these Church appearances and
she is praying for the death of Joe
Biden here now I know when you hear it
you might say that's sort of ambiguous
it's really not ambiguous if you
understand the Bible verses so let's
listen to what Lauren bobert had to say
and then go from there God said that he
was the provider I know that Jesus said
that he that we would be blessed but I
just don't know about this month and
Jesus is right there at the table with
you Sam
what kind of conversation is this
why are you talking like this and why
are you sad
Jesus don't you know we're out of money
kovitz hit they shut everything down Joe
Biden's President we don't know what to
do Lord
all right
that's all right we pray for our
presidents uh you know it says
let his days be few and another take his
office
that's why I files articles of
impeachment for Joe Biden
[Applause]
now you might say David with all due
respect that's pretty ambiguous it's not
ambiguous if you understand the full
context of what she is quoting the verse
that Lauren bobare references there is
Psalm 109 8 and it is clearly about
praying for the death of an enemy in
office because she quoted let his days
be few and let another take his office
and then the rest of it is let his
children be fatherless and his wife a
widow you don't become a widow just
because your husband gets impeached as
she talks about you become a widow
because your husband dies your children
become fatherless not because you're
impeached but because you die and Lauren
bobert also I can't believe I'm using
this term but she preached this message
in June as well praise the Lord I hope
that blesses somebody but I
I do want you to know I pray for our
president Psalm 109 8.
says may his days be few and another
take his office
[Applause]
Hallelujah yeah so that's exactly the
same thing she knows exactly what the
verse is she knows the context what
we're talking about here is praying for
the death of Joe Biden at minimum every
single one of these places where she's
preaching
needs to lose its tax-exempt status
that's is an absolute minimum and we've
talked about that before but there are
people like Lauren bobert going to
tonight's State of the Union who should
be screened very very closely by secret
service that is what is insane the calls
are coming from inside the house now one
defense that I saw made is
she's speaking statistically Joe Biden's
80 years old
80 year olds don't tend to live much
longer well if you if you really want to
play that game right and and we can do
that uh you can look at the Social
Security life expectancy tables these
are Actuarial tables and if you are 80
years old this is from 2019 I don't know
that the numbers have been updated since
then but based into these are the
numbers used this year from 2019. if you
are an 80 year old male
you have a 5.6 chance of dying in the
following year and you are expected to
live another 8.4 years as an 80 year old
male in the U.S in 2019
so for those saying this is just about
letting father time take his course or
whatever the case may be you may be
disappointed to know the Actuarial
numbers on which Social Security is
based disgusting woman an absolute shame
and embarrassment is Lauren bobert and I
really hope that secret service is going
to keep a close eye on her tonight we're
going to take a quick break make sure
you are subscribed to the show on
YouTube at youtube.com the davidpackman
show very powerful live stream coming up
tonight
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
if you don't understand something it's
very difficult to be prepared for it to
know how to synthesize it to know how to
deal with it and we are seeing such
dangerous examples of this coming in
general from the divisive narrative
being promulgated by the American right
wing in a complete vacuum of policy as
we've talked about before where it's not
even that the policy is whatever the
policy doesn't even matter they don't
even really talk about policy anymore
and we're going to look at a couple
examples of that here and they come from
Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson now
one of the reasons that Carlson is
particularly dangerous is that similarly
to someone like a Ben Shapiro
Tucker Carlson
speaks very confidently the tone of
people like Tucker and Ben Shapiro are
that they are extraordinarily confident
in telling you how things are
the reason that Tucker is arguably even
more dangerous than Ben Shapiro is that
to some degree Ben Shapiro is more
readily understood as giving his opinion
whereas the context and the sort of
production of Tucker's show where it
just looks like yet another Fox news
program
actually tricks more people into
thinking that Tucker Carlson is giving
you news and as we know when it when the
rubber meets the road and the lawyers
come out because there's a lawsuit Fox
News lawyers are very quick to say
Tucker Carlson is an Entertainer he's
not a news person look at these couple
of clips from yesterday uh from Tucker
Carlson's program in this first clip
Tucker Carlson bemoans I guess what he
considers some kind of woke affirmative
action of sorts by pointing out that Joe
Biden has appointed quite a number of
black women to be judges take a look at
this out of 97 federal judges confirmed
under Joe Biden total number of white
men five
22 are black women
so this is race-based hiring it's
illegal but it's also not about looking
like America it's about punishing people
now that could not be less true and what
Tucker Carlson doesn't tell you when he
says well hold on a second
97 federal judges confirmed under Biden
22 were black women that's like almost a
quarter that doesn't make any sense that
doesn't look like America but you have
to zoom out and you have to realize
there are currently about 1400 sitting
federal judges 1400 it's actually
1407 more than half are white men not
just white more than half are white men
and only four and a half percent are
black women so when you say it's illegal
it's not representative of the way
America looks or whatever the case may
be understand that African Americans
make up 13 of the American population
you would expect if black women and
girls are roughly half of that 13 that
would be six and a half percent you
still have black women
underrepresented by a third
among judges now I am not someone who
says we need exact equality of outcome
you're never going to have that it's an
unreasonable thing to expect if I came
to you and I said in order for society
to be fair in every single place we must
have
50.3 percent women 13 black people uh
one percent Jews or whatever the
percentage isn't it that would be a very
unreasonable thing to say but when you
zoom out there are places where we look
and we have to say this can't be by
chance when you zoom out and you say
well
46 presidents and zero women in a
country that's 50.3 percent women that
is a statistic that doesn't make sense
we don't need 50.3 percent of presidents
to be women you might have a situation
where women are less interested in being
president than men and it doesn't have
to be because of discrimination I'm
completely open to that you know the the
right Wingers love to say this thing
where they go hey you know what
if you really want equality why aren't
you fighting for 50.3 percent of
longshoremen it actually the term has
man in it right why aren't you fighting
for 50.3 percent of longshoremen and
bricklayers to be women well that that's
not actually what we're saying and there
are all sorts of different reasons why
women may be less interested in being
bricklayers and it doesn't have to be
because of discrimination so it's not
about equality of outcome but the very
argument Tucker is making is turned on
its head by the fact Tucker says
22 out of 97 judges being black women
isn't representative of America's
demographics well no but we have such a
deficit demographically among among
judges that what Joe Biden is doing is
only partially making the demographics
actually represent America so
it's a bogus argument but it's ripe and
perfect for his audience here's one
other
um uh just clip from yesterday and again
it's just these are talking point Comas
that Tucker goes into here it's
something about transgender Satanism
there's some Shameless about this they
don't even care
tonight's transgender Satanism brought
to you by Pfizer and check their
products in your body
I look more awesome that is a very very
concerning uh laugh so listen uh there
is horrible stuff happening on Tucker
Carlson's program and if you were saying
well fine there's horrible stuff
happening there but Tucker is never
going to say well we should be defending
George Santos is he well let's uh talk
about that next
there is apparently no low too low for
Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson who
is now issuing a delusional defense of
George Anthony kitara De volder Santos
you might know him as just George Santos
the lying Republican congressman who
lied about everything Tucker Carlson has
found a way to defend him we are going
to look at a clip this is really a
clinic in disinformation and Tucker
Carlson starts by talking about Joe
Biden but it morphs into a defend of
Defense of George Santos and it is
fascinating to see see if you can pick
out the rhetorical tools that Tucker
uses here I'm going to try to keep a
list of them and then we will discuss so
we haven't watched a ton of cable news
recently but we assumed with mass
layoffs underway across the USA by the
way this wee thing is funny you're
talking about yourself Tucker I mean an
egg shortage crumbling cities the
prospect of a third world war looming on
the near Horizon right we assumed we
knew what the other channels would be
covering because they're an awful lot of
threats out there what we didn't know
until we tuned into MSNBC and CNN the
other day was that all of those threats
go by a single name
and that name
is Mr George Santos George Santos
Winks into his new job as a freshman
member of Congress and just months from
his previous life of near total
anonymity right George Santos has
somehow transformed into the single most
dangerous and historically significant
figure on the global stage today so we
have here already two tools that are
used we have what about ism
and we have
um you could call it reductio at
absurdum you could call it straw Manning
uh so so the what about ism is Tucker
Carlson shifting from a discussion about
Biden to one about how George Santos has
been treated which are actually two
completely different things no matter
what Tucker tries to tell you and then
the sort of straw Manning is the idea
that Democrats are telling you Santos is
the most dangerous guy in the world
Democrats aren't telling you Santos is
they're saying he's laughably dishonest
and has no place in the House of
Representatives which is true
George Santos is like 9 11 in human form
nothing will ever be the same now that
George Santos is here you will never
forget the moment you first saw George
Santos where were you when George Santos
was elected it's a story you will tell
your grandchildren watch
on Capitol Hill this is George Santos's
reality it seems almost every day there
are new questions about the Freshman
congressman's past some stretching back
more than a decade
you keep up with all the Santos lies and
controversies he is now out trumping
Trump in terms of flooding The Zone with
excrement not just saying that he played
volleyball but he had a scholarship that
he slayed teams from Harvard and Yale
the perfect portrayal of self-loathing
that he clearly is so disgusted with
himself and so disgusted with the life
that he's led a life of Lies a life of
fables people didn't decide because they
thought he was somebody totally totally
different it was a lie and a fraudulent
election he has to resign not a
Volleyball Champion and he doesn't
appear to be a champion of the people
either the voters did not elect you Mr
Santos they elected a version of you
invented by your imagination sadly
George Santos represents so much that is
wrong today lies denial
and the death of Shame
it was a stolen election it was a stolen
election you heard Adam kinzinger say it
and CNN filled in the blanks there's
false equivalency which is also another
rhetorical tool which is that the left
is saying Santos stole an election in
the same way that Trump is saying that
Biden stole an election and of course
the two things could not be more
different so there's false equivalency
this is really a clinic in logical
fallacies it's not just that George
Santos claimed that he once played
volleyball in college played volleyball
in college
it's worse than that indescribably worse
George Santos told other people out loud
and ceiling can exclusively confirm this
that he had a volleyball scholarship all
right you get the point we're not going
to do the full four and a half minutes
of this Tucker Carlson has found a way
to come to George Santos's defense as
someone who is just now a target of the
latest woke mob I saw a really good
comment on Reddit about this and what
that comment said was hopefully a
hundred years from now if the U.S
survives the next hundred years this
sort of stuff this era will be seen as
the Golden Age of ignorance and school
kids will hear about the things that
were said and believed the military is
really in control right now Obama's in
control George Santos is actually a fine
person to be a member of the House of
rep all this stuff kids will look back
at 2023 and they will say how did humans
believe that stuff back then it will be
sort of like when we say how did they
think at one point that leeches cured
all sorts of different medical
conditions we say that's so silly how
could anybody think that hopefully in
the future people will learn about this
era and they will say wow what a stupid
era really the Golden Age of of of
ignorance there and this is really a
good test for how far will they go is
there nothing they won't defend if it
has an R next to its name him and if the
left doesn't like it we saw they went
for Trump
now even with George Santos they're
finding a way to defend him it is of how
far will this go sort of situation and
sadly I don't think we want to know the
answer because they will go very very
far we will have all of these clips that
I played for you on both our Instagram
and our YouTube accounts find us on
Instagram at davidpackman show find us
on YouTube at youtube.com the David
Pacman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today I'm
going to be speaking with Chris Tarbell
former FBI special agent and now
founding partner at naxo was involved in
the eventual takedown of the Silk Road
which I've spoken a little bit about
before Chris great to have you on today
really appreciate it ah thanks for
having me on David I appreciate it so
you know to start just somewhere as I
read about the story of how uh Ross
Albrecht and and the Silk Road will were
ultimately taken down one of the things
that is often described as the story is
told in many of the books about it is
that it's really like the prototypical
example of different law enforcement
agencies in the U.S not working well
together which is sort of like this
narrative that often exists about well
the FBI wants credit well this also
involved HSI and it involved all these
different agencies and the Silk Road
would have been taken down much sooner
were egos put aside that's a story
that's often told do you think that
that's fair as far as the way that it
went
uh no not exactly
um you know the the other agencies were
doing good investigations HSI had good
investigations going as far as going up
the chain
um but unfortunately this is a new way
of dealing drugs I mean this was
um you know they were the buyers didn't
know who the dealers were the dealers
didn't know who the admins were
um you know and so it really was just
you know it didn't go the a normal
investigative route you know I wanted
this new Cyber route so for people who
don't know what what the Silk Road was
can you give them sort of a brief
synopsis I mean it was it was a dark web
site that was originally I believe uh
dealing mostly in illegal drugs but
actually came to be much more than that
yeah it was an online uh dark Market
website uh operated on the Tor Network
with the onion router this was a hidden
network developed by the Navy uh back in
the late 90s
um and you can't trace IPS traditionally
through it it works on a different
protocol that kind of hides where the
traffic is coming from and going to uh
but it also worked through anonymity
through cryptocurrency this was the
early stages of Bitcoin so you literally
could go on there and buy almost
anything it was a 1.2 Billion Dollar
Empire by the time we took it down now
there were two things you couldn't Buy
on Silk Road
um you couldn't buy guns because that
was on a different website and you also
couldn't buy fake IDs all right sorry
fake um college degrees you could buy
fake IDs you couldn't get a fake call
college degree they didn't want you to
be uh like a doctor
um and uh and not really have the
education when this started to become an
investigation that involved multiple
agencies
what was really or let me put a
different way what were their concerns
about where it could go or was the
concern really what was already taking
place with it
um really it was what was already taking
place
um you know in the FBI and I can't speak
for HSI or IRS or DEA in their
investigations
um the FBI investigation really came out
of we had a lot of cases around that
time it was 2011 2012. a lot of cases
just ended uh it was Tor we can't do
anything about it
um so we had just done a big case
involving Anonymous and the arresting of
Sabu Hector montagueor and one of the
other guys on on the anonymous case was
a guy named Jeremy Haman and he was
arrested and using Tor so it was one of
those interesting things we didn't do
anything
um with tour it just happened that's how
he's hiding and it took us an extra six
months to find him but once that case
was over we started sitting around and
thinking about maybe we should take a
look at a tour and see we can do there's
so many cases being closed
um just because it's it comes up as a
Tor IP address if I recall correctly a
big kind of breaking point in starting
to look at Ross Albrecht was someone
involved in the investigation and it's
been a little while since since I I read
the the book about the investigation
someone put together
an old handle that Ross used on some
Message Board which then they figured
out oh they're that that's I recognize
that that's also appearing elsewhere
remind us of that detail but maybe more
importantly how long did the Silk Road
investigation go before the name Russell
brick ever actually was mentioned
well so that there's a there's a path
there there's a story there that you
know it's kind of difficult so
there we the connecting the the word the
name you're looking for is Frosty yes so
someone on a on a message board way back
at the start of Silk Road posted uh uh
hey I'm starting this onion site and
it's going to use cryptocurrency if
anybody has any programming help reach
out to me at Frosty
um and when I was posted in the username
frosty in the Forum right but he said
reach out to me at ross.olbrick
gmail.com right which again is a clue in
our world yes um not until we found the
server and was able to go through sort
of the networks of the server and find
that uh there was a backup server in
Philadelphia
um and then there was a computer that
was reaching out to the backup server
and the name of the computer was Frosty
um so now we have you know this this
computer being run by DPR dreadfire
Roberts the guy who operated Silk Road
um you know and then this posting of
from Frosty with the email address Ross
Albrecht gmail.com and that was
originally the way that the
investigation turned to look
specifically at Albrecht
yeah I mean we had to develop a few
other things before we knew that he was
in the Pacific coast time
um because there was a jabber server uh
that he had set up that's a
communication server for his admins to
talk on and we knew that his time frame
was around then but that specifically
that was the where we connected Ross
through that Frosty connection if you
look at um critiques of the way that
Albrecht was ultimately prosecuted it
seems what most often comes up is
something along the lines of you know
the drug part increasingly there's a
view that drugs should be decriminalized
at minimum many should actually be
legalized more commonly with cannabis
than with cocaine but this is sort of
like the way things have kind of moved
over the last decade 15 years
particularly Libertarians like Albrecht
subscribe to that ideology and there are
many who say that were it only the drugs
alone really what was happening
shouldn't actually have been against the
law however it went over into you could
hire Hitmen on the Silk Road and it went
over into all this other stuff that I
think is more universally thought of as
like you know that that stuff definitely
shouldn't be legal when someone like you
or others in the FBI are investigating
something like this how much or do does
it matter at all what your personal
feelings are about for example which
drugs if any should be illegal or
decriminalized or legalized or does it
quite literally never enter into the
work as you are investigating something
like this
it really never enters into the work I
mean so I I was assigned to New York I
was a special agent in New York and and
I like to say in New York you know it's
so specialized there's uh you know let's
I jokingly say there's a bank robbery
and the first question is was the bank
robber left-handed or right-handed
because there's one Squad handles left
in bank robbery the others handles
right-handed
um you know where you're put on a squad
and we were very we were criminal cyber
intrusions
um so we were the hacking criminal
hacking crew um that was that was our
Squad and there's another Squad that did
National Security hacking so really you
know I was just investigating hacking um
and really tour had come up
um we had partnered up with start with
Southern District of New York who had a
case with uh the DEA at the time and
then brought in the IRS and so really I
was looking at 18 USC
um 10 30 violation of hacking growth and
that was one of the things sold on Silk
Road was was hacking tools or hacks for
hire
um and so that was sort of the Nexus but
really there when we opened up the Silk
Road case we opened up 25 other onion
sites and it really was more looking
into using Tor as a way of hiding
criminal activity
when you see the sentence that Albrecht
ultimately got which was I believe two
life sentences without the possibility
of parole last 40 years plus 40 years
okay does that seem like the right
sentence for what he did
that is not my decision you know I I'm a
part of the you know that's the thank
God the government has different
branches you know I'm part of the I was
part of the executive branch no doubt
the laws
um you know the legislative branch does
the you know what what laws there are
and the judicial branches come up with
the punishment so that that's way beyond
my scope of expertise no but as a guy
who now is out and just might have an
opinion I I really don't have an opinion
on it yeah and I'm not suggest I don't
know that I mean sometimes people say
that because they don't want to answer I
I actually am open to the idea that you
really just that's not the way you think
about these things you have a particular
role in this whole thing yeah certainly
I I mean I I I'm not I wouldn't be upset
if uh someone I arrested you know was
let go um I mean I wrecked I arrested
Hector montagueor uh he spent you know
months in jail was facing 125 years but
did a great job I'm not offended by all
the work I put in and he got out and
didn't got got he was only in prison for
for nine months for for what he did
um you know that doesn't offend me in
any sort of way that so yeah I really
don't have an opinion on it what's the
current state of dark web marketplaces
because it's not really a topic in the
news right now but it's sort of like by
definition the idea is it's dark web so
you don't necessarily know about it
these aren't indexed websites you need a
special browser to access it do you know
much about the current state of these
types of marketplaces I do I'm still
involved in them so yeah um you know you
would ask me right after Silk Road and
right after Ross got sentenced all that
you know two life sentences in 40 years
I would have said it would have gone
down I would no one would do this it's
crazy but it actually exploded right
after that
um there was a big um state of you know
people setting up these sites and
stealing people's cryptocurrency but now
it's becoming to you know there's places
you know and I don't want to tell kids
how to get there right
um you know but but there are many many
dark Market websites out there that you
can still still do many more than they
were back in the day are they ever based
in the United States or is that just
like the height of of ignorance to
approach it that way
you still do it in the United States um
you know it's it's sort of a
whack-a-mole if someone makes a mistake
a configuration issue or something like
that and law enforcement gets them
um but the latest takedowns haven't
really used infrastructure in the United
States that I've seen you mentioned the
connection to crypto and that crypto was
often the payment method that was used
one of the interesting and full
disclosure I have no emotional
attachment to this question I also have
no opinion I was in not early but you
know 2016 I bought some Bitcoin and it
did really well and I've mostly sold all
of it and I have no opinion as to where
it's going or how much it's used for
criminality one of the arguments that
was made earlier about Bitcoin was it's
overwhelmingly used for criminal
activities but my understanding is that
when the Silk Road was shut down the uh
throughput of transactions barely
changed at all which sort of would be a
Counterpoint to the idea that Bitcoin
was primarily being used for criminal
transactions did you and your
investigative work come to have an
opinion about that and and how regularly
criminal motivations were were at play
for Bitcoin transactions
so you know in my world as an FBI agent
I only looked at criminal activity so
you know I saw it attach it to
everything I mean it really was the
birth of ransomware I mean we've had
encryption for you know 75 years you
know digital encryption that sort of
thing all the way back to you know the
Nazis uh uh encryption you know their
Enigma machines
um you know so that's not new what
really was the rise for ransomware was
the popularity of cryptocurrency
um so you know we're fighting we're
still fighting that to this day on that
sort of thing
um so you know I am a technologist I
liked cryptocurrency I see the point of
it I liked it you know two people can
meet in a far-off place and making
transaction and it's locked in place
within you know 60 minutes at most
um but I see a lot of criminal activity
connected to it what are you seeing now
in terms of the trends of the Cyber
threats scams fishing at the individual
level if you're able to comment on it
you know about five years ago I was
getting a lot of the hey you owe tax
money money and we're sending the police
to your house to which I would say send
them sounds interesting obviously I know
I don't you know I'm not giving you any
money Social Security scams give us
access to your computer and we'll like
log into your bank that that sort of
stuff I'm not being targeted by that
anymore I'm getting a lot more sort of
like telemarketing stuff like wanting to
sell me warranties on vehicles I don't
even have and this sort of thing what
are the trends right now what's going on
so we're seeing a lot of phishing scams
for uh crypto theft so any sort of like
accounts that are taken over where it's
uh sent out that you're part of a crypto
network if you're part of an exchange
you know you'll start getting a lot of
phishing emails and the the fishing the
the phone calls
um give me access and then because it's
so easy you don't have to they give
access to their computer and all and you
know just take the wallets right out
right there you don't have to convince
them to do anything more
um I think one of the biggest Trends and
so I host a podcast with Hector monzagor
um taboo the guy arrested hackering the
fed and he made a prediction and I agree
with him that this year we're going to
see a lot more Insider threats people
inside networks who we give access to
um are going to be stealing data um you
know he kind of made that prediction
based on the large technology layoffs
we've we've seen lately
um but we're seeing more and more you
know networks have been protected from
the outside and very few people are
doing things to protect internal Network
stuff what's the lowest hanging fruit
right now just for individuals in terms
of protecting themselves
what can they do better yeah I mean it
you know I know people who for example
they just don't pick up their phone
anymore and just by doing that unless
they they quite literally know who's
calling them even if they think it might
be their bank they just do not pick up
the phone as an example and that right
there knocks 50 down or you know that
type of thing yeah no I would definitely
do that you know the the email stuff is
still the phishing stuff but one of the
easiest things you can do is called
segmentation
um there's no much no more flat networks
at work you'll never see just one router
and everyone connects to the same router
in any office but we're seeing that at
home still a lot of people just have one
router they give their passwords out to
people that come and visit or or and
that sort of thing or when they connect
internet other things when your
thermostat is connected to your router a
lot of thermostats and things like that
um have hard-coded passwords or they
don't change the administrative
passwords well that's a whole right into
your network so
um segmentations either through vlans or
having physical different devices
um have you know more than one router in
your house in and secure it that way oh
that's interesting so for example you
could you could set up a separate Wi-Fi
network
for the thermostats alone and you on
your phone never connect to that Network
yeah anything you do banking on should
not be on the same as your Internet of
Things
um especially things that punch what I
call punching holes in the firewall so
because you can change your thermostat
from outside your house right because
you can look at cameras that you've had
connected to your internet those are
holes in your firewall
um that means that they you know it's an
entry point into the the defense system
um so you know have a different network
that doesn't have that connected to it
used for your you know banking logging
into banking accounts and that sort of
thing all right that's useful and
actionable and it's not unrealistic you
know sometimes the tips you read are
like yes I could do that but I'm
basically segregating myself out of the
way Society is operating which is not
practical useful it's like a diet that
you can only sustain for a week it's not
super useful long term yeah
um
deep now so it is it's really a thing
you can do and you know configuration
there's a lot of YouTube videos out
there that can help you configure you
know different networks we have been
speaking with former FBI special agent
Chris Tarbell now a founding partner at
naxo Chris really appreciate your time
and your insights today
thanks so much for having me on I
appreciate it it was fun
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right it's been a while but let's
talk a little bit about Carrie Lake who
is moving on to her next likely grift
running for Senate in Arizona it seems
maybe she's getting ready to give up on
taking that governorship back that was
stolen from her which of course wasn't
stolen she simply lost to Katie Hobbs
the rightful winner and the now governor
of the state of Arizona Carrie lake is
starting to tease that she may indeed
run for Senate we are going to look at a
video from Charlie Kirk's program you
might notice Charlie Kirk now adopting a
totally new look getting himself some
big glasses and wearing a shirt and tie
and I guess maybe needing to be taken
more seriously or something along those
lines he interviews Carrie Lake and
Carrie Lake says you know uh I I it is
something I am looking at very strongly
and we already have polling data of what
this will look like let's take a look at
this clip some people are clamoring for
you to run for the U.S Senate very few
people I can tell you that I I had a lot
of people reach out this weekend over it
yeah we got people they're contacting
that's exactly what people do they go
hey you know what I want Carrie Lake to
run I'm going to call Charlie Kirk to
tell him about it Diego running Cinema
might run therefore there's a very clear
Lane for a three-way race is this
something you're interested in something
you're entertaining what are your
thoughts uh yes I am entertaining it I
mean my number one priority is our court
case and I have full confidence she has
to say that because you have to keep
that grift going until you've completely
dried until it has completely dried up
but also she's entertaining a different
way to help arizonans which is to run
for Senator I guess our court case and I
have hope that we'll get a judge to do
the right thing but I'm also looking at
um what happens if we don't get a a
decent ruling in that right and they
want me to go away they want our
movement to go away I represent we the
people and if they want us gone so badly
that they're willing to steal an
election then which didn't happen I'm
not going to let them have that I won't
go away and I've seen some internal
polling that shows I am the only
Republican who can beat these other two
I find both of them incredibly dangerous
to the people of Arizona I find them you
know Pearson Cinemas voting record Being
83 or rather 93 percent of the time
voting for Joe Biden's agenda I find
Ruben Gallego being a self-admitted
socialist
um really frightening for Arizona and if
I'm the only Republican who can beat
them I would be willing to jump in
there's always this martyrdom language
did you hear at the end how she says if
I'm the only Republican who can beat
them right this is despite her best
interests if she just finds herself in
the position of being the only person
that could actually come in and save the
State of Arizona she's willing to do it
she's not she doesn't want to do it
she's an excited excited about doing it
she's willing to do it rather than the
more interesting and exciting things I
guess that she could be doing now we do
have some early polling uh in in that
hypothetical matchup we talked about
this in late December Paul finds Cinema
gets only 13 support in a three-way race
with Gallego and lake and roughly the
way that it looks right now
um and we have a longer clip just
talking about this polling it's
basically a tie between Gallego and Lake
uh with or without Kirsten Cinema so it
was something like 48 to 47 I think it
was when you don't include Kirsten
Cinema
in Lake versus Gallego excuse me and if
you do include Kirsten Cinema
um it's something like 4041 and so what
was interesting about that is Carrie
Lake and uh uh Gallego roughly receiving
50 50 support
from Kirsten Cinema voters I'm going to
take a sip of water
thank you I don't want one of those Fox
News moments so uh will carry Lake
ultimately run I don't know if it'll get
her attention if it'll get her back to
Mar-A-Lago or whatever the case may be
but Kerry Lake going to do whatever it
is that is best for her
all right I want to talk just a little
bit more about Charlie Kirk but this is
really not about Charlie Kirk this is
actually about uh the trans kids issue
and a new version of the same tired
homophobic talking point from 15 years
ago or even longer let's start with a
clip to tell you what I'm talking about
here is Charlie Kirk saying that Tick
Tock is turning kids transgender turning
kids transgender the language really
matters here listen to what he has to
say I want to play a piece of tape here
Jack and get your reaction
this is Senator Tom Cotton talking about
how hey if you're fired up about the
balloon wait till I tell you about Tick
Tock play cut two
uh well uh China has been waging a cold
war against the United States for
decades and unfortunately not many of
our leaders have acknowledged that they
want to deny that it's happening but
when a nation like China is waging a
cold war against us the only choice is
whether to win or to lose I think this
spy balloon that so vividly uh went
across America is a very high profile
reminder to Americans about uh what the
Chinese Communists have been up to
because I got to tell your viewers if
they're worried about a spy balloon
flying across Middle America let me tell
them about the tick tock app that they
may have on their phone and what it
means for their security and their
privacy and that of their children as
well yeah and not to mention Tick Tock
is turning kids Trends Jack we're
already in a cold war the the the degree
the Casual nature with which these
people say in the insane things yeah and
by the way Tick Tock is turning kids
trans now couple different things here
that I think are important to point out
first and foremost the Charlie Kirk show
is on Tick Tock okay he has not as many
followers as we do fine but over 200 000
followers on Tick Tock the Charlie Kirk
show if Charlie Kirk thinks that Tick
Tock is a problem then why is Charlie
Kirk on Tick Tock making the problem
problem worse by directing viewers of
his onto that platform but I want to
talk about this idea of turning kids
Trends this is Verbatim what used to be
said about kids being turned gay
15 years ago on this show I would
interview I would interview virulent
homophobes like Peter Le Barbara and
chaplain Gordon klingenschmidt and the
Westboro Baptist Church people and uh Dr
Paul Cameron is he still alive by the
way I'm actually curious about that Dr
Paul Cameron let's see
uh apparently he is yeah he's 83 years
old so I would interview these folks and
remember at the time they Brian Fisher
was another one they never really were
too worried about lesbians gay men was
their focus and one of the things they
would say is kids are being convinced
Boys in particular are being convinced
to be gay now they've switched to kids
are being convinced to be trans you
can't convince people to be gay or trans
now I want to do this thoroughly because
I think that that this entire talking
point is BS and it's dangerous but there
is one conversation that we can have
about this okay you really can't
convince people to be gay or trans if
that you know if it's seven or something
you had started to say hey don't you
find these little boys attractive David
or it's great to like boys instead of
girl whatever right there's no way that
you can convince people to be gay or
trans what can happen
is that people who are gay or trans
might not be comfortable expressing that
because of social stigma or pressure or
fears or whatever and that if they
perceive that it would be fine for them
to just be who they are they don't have
to hide it you might see more young
people willing to express who they
actually are that is absolutely true
that when you reduce stigma and you
reduce fear people are just more
comfortable telling you who they are now
all of that being said
I am open to the idea that the discourse
can temporarily encourage people to see
solutions to a problem they're having in
whatever is prevalent in the narrative
and what I mean by that is there are now
here I'm not talking about people who
are trans what I am talking about is
there are people who for all sorts of
different reasons in their lives come to
have what we might call a crisis they
aren't happy with their lives or with
who they are or with how things are
going or whatever the case may be I know
people who become fixated in an
unhealthy way for example on a
particular diet I am aware of someone
who uh was having problems uh in in
their life and they decided it was Diet
related they believed their food was
making them depressed and all of these
different things and so they said I'm
only going to eat fruit and nuts and and
they did that for a year and it was
completely extreme and terrible and then
they said you know the problem is my
diet but it's the wrong diet I'm gonna
go on the
um meat diet essentially and they were
eating you know sticks of butter and 10
eggs for breakfast or whatever and then
they realized I just I what I really
needed was actually just to sort out
emotional problems I was having and I
should just be eating a normal diet I am
open although I have not seen evidence
that this is going on I am open to the
idea that for kids of a certain age
where there are these sort of struggles
and identity issues that they might
temporarily if what they are hearing
about is being trans they might wonder
maybe that's the issue that I'm having
and then of course at some point they
would realize that that it is actually
not that I am open to all of this other
stuff you can convince kids to be trans
there's no evidence of it whatsoever and
it's quite frankly absurd that Charlie
Kirk just so offhandedly says it we have
a voicemail number that number is 2192
David P many comments about my mustache
that I came back from vacation with
here's one
hi David I love the 70s porn stash that
you've got going on the mustache thank
you I've always kind of wondered when
you put on those Teddy Stratford shirts
in the front of your shirt looks so nice
with no creases or wrinkles like you
just have like a massive hairy beautiful
chest under there or is it just a shirt
yeah no I uh I uh you know I have thick
Semitic hair uh all over my body
certainly but but most of the comments
about the mustache quite negative
actually quite negative
um my my girlfriend is worried um that I
might end up uh she she actually thinks
I I might end up profiled by police and
I said no no no no and she said don't
drive a white van
um but no the the mustache is just a
joke
and it will be gone soon but I
appreciate everybody's concern we will
talk on the bonus show today about Ron
DeSantis setting himself up to take
control of Disney's Orlando District
under a new bill it's crazy what's
happening down there in Florida North
Carolina senators are sending a
controversial LGBT Bill to a vote after
a wild Committee hearing which we will
discuss and Ted Cruz now says the
Grammys the Grammys are evil after Sam
Smith had a Satan themed set and it
really triggered right-wingers all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com to get
access to the bonus show and remember
that tonight just after 8 PM Eastern 5
p.m Pacific I will be live with Joe
Biden State of the Union Address I hope
to see you then
foreign